hello welcome back to game sports
coverage of e3 2016 I'm delighted to be
joined by mr. David cage I guess the
writer director creative leads yeah
whatever
at the same time all of these things
great to have you here thank you for
having me thanks so much great to see
Detroit as well once again um if you
don't mind oh I want to talk to you
about one of your earlier games one of
my favorite games just briefly before we
iMac Rondo nomad soul oh my god Quantic
Dream's first your dad old yes I know
yeah a gray hair I turned 30 this year
but I loved that game and obviously
earlier this year we lost David Bowie in
January and that was I believe the only
game that he was was in or the oh yeah
so what was it like working with him do
you remember as their father well it was
my very first game really and yeah
remember the first time we met actually
I mean we were supposed to meet in the
publishers office in London and I
thought he would never come I thought
all this was just you know it never
happened and actually it was like 10
minutes late alright and we're all
looking at our watches thinking oh he's
never gonna make it and then 10 minutes
later he arrived in the apologize for
being late because of the traffic
and he came with a young kid it was
maybe 14 years old right I mean he said
okay this is my video game expert is my
son Duncan Jones yes we became of course
the director that we know yeah of moon
and of course world of warcraft and so
it was really funny because I met both
at the same time yeah we had a wonderful
collaboration together that lasted a
year right and he wrote about 12
original songs and and I had the
pleasure to direct him in studio because
he would play two roles in the game so
well it's a fantastic experience of
course as you can imagine and he was a
fantastic person right that was actually
how I found out about David Bowie was I
I had never found his music and then I
remember walking into was at the bar or
where you know the band is playing for
the first time and it takes control away
from you and absolutely does the music
video and then I was like what is this
my auntie found out and bought me a
David Bowie album then so I introduced
you
thank you so my god for giving me the
gift of David Bowie and to all of it a
pleasure
Quantic Dream obviously you've created a
bunch of games since Fahrenheit or
Indigo Prophecy depending on what side
of the Atlantic you live and so the last
one we played was beyond two souls
another collaboration with a bunch of
famous actors yes at one of you Tooting
things about Detroit seeing it in
initially is that there doesn't seem to
be any familiar faces we don't have a
Willem Dafoe we don't have any sort of
celebrity in it at least so far is that
the case well you know our goal has
never been to look for the most you know
famous people to get them in our games
we're just to find the right actor for
the role and in this case we worked with
a bunch of young but very talented
actors and the first one we introduced
at Paris games week is the character is
the character of Kara yes incarnated by
a young actress called Valerie curry and
she was in a TV series called the
following recently and she's a she's a
fantastic actress and of course she was
Kara in the shorts that we did buy in
2012 long time ago now so same actress
in here at e3 we came with a new scene
and we absolutely wanted to come with a
playable scene because you know with our
games it's time we introduced a new game
the first question we get is how does it
play is it still quite mysterious for
some people to know how you can play a
story-driven game so we wanted to come
with this playable scene and introducing
the character of Connor who is
incarnated by a another very talented
actor called Brian Deckard let's talk
about some of your I guess influences
that sort of create this world what type
of world are we looking at here
obviously you know very you can talk
about things like Blade Runner in terms
of the sort of like Android sort of
human relationship thing happening there
and but what type of world are we
looking at in Detroit how far in the
future is it what what does Detroit look
like so Detroit we call it an alien or
reader it's set in a near future and in
the city of Detroit Michigan of course
and it's important for us that it's a
near future it's not sci-fi so there's
no flying car no laser gun right just
all world but twenty years from now in
this this world in this world the
technology allowed the creation of
androids that looks peak movie
like human beings except they are just
machines so they took most of human jobs
as you could expect and so there are
millions of them all across the country
and the story starts where when some of
them start to show strange behaviors
some of them leave without any reason
and others kill themselves which is very
unusual for a team and others start to
be aggressive against humans and we're
just at the very beginning it's very few
androids having this dysfunctions and we
are going to discover why what happened
at cetera et cetera what was important
for me was to take a different angle
then then most stories about androids I
didn't want to tell another story where
the humans would be the good guys and
they would need to face these evil
androids and I'll have a virus and we
need to kill them before they kill us
it's been done before very well I wanted
to create a story where we would play
the androids and see the world through
their eyes and write their point of view
and maybe there are the good guys and
maybe we are the bad guys it's always an
interesting part of your games as they
are I suppose movie them the more modern
ones is that the idea of playing the
story through multiple perspectives
presumably that will also be the
absolutely we play more than one
character we introduce again Kara and
Connor is the second character that is
playable and who knows maybe there are
more wonderfully I'm sure we'll find out
over the coming months and yeah that
then we showed I guess there's this
thing when you the games that you create
are always so striking and so sort of
like film like that
I guess maybe audience is sort of we
assume that they're incredibly linear
and that there isn't much choice because
that's the case for most video games
that sort of take that right and was
there a sort of a very determined
mission to sort of show that okay here
is one small scene and this is like the
various different ways in which it plays
it absolutely I mean we we want to
create an experience in which the player
is not only the actor of the story but
he is the co-writer so basically based
on his choices this decision is going to
tell his own story and his story is
going to be different from from someone
else's story and all this happens
through game plays so we'd only didn't
want to tell the story through cutscenes
we want the player to play and as he
plays he tells the story and that was
really our starting point
realreal moto for for every decision we
make we wanted to create the more but we
call this banding you know for bending
stories right
but it's branching narrative and
basically we wanted to create the more
bending game we have ever created that
Quantic Dream right well is that always
the mission for the next game because
obviously we know with heavy rain that
was that was the sort of modus operandi
that was the mission it seemed and then
with beyond two souls similarly but you
know in a different way you know game
after game we we don't like formulas in
a way we try to reinvent what we're
doing we try to challenge ourselves and
we have the immense luxury of having
time and support from from Sony to try
things to experiment and and maybe fail
maybe succeed maybe find something or
find nothing but at least we can explore
and try and each story you want to tell
must find its own voice its sound
language in some in some way and so game
after game we try to find the best
gameplay the best interface that will
better feed the story you want to tell
and for Detroit it became very obvious
from the beginning that that would be
the best choice having different points
of view also having characters we can
die
which is also something very interesting
because I never felt confortable with
game over in video games to be honest
especially when they are story driven
because it's always a strange thing this
game over situations where you die and
then we go back in time and you need to
replay this again until you play the
game the way the game design I wanted
you to play which in a in a in a
fighting game is fine or shooting game
but in a story driven game doesn't make
any sense right yeah so what we try to
do was to give a narrative consequences
to your failures and make sure that
maybe you will be injured maybe you will
lose something maybe you will miss an
information or or something or maybe
ultimately your character can die but
there will be a logical consequence to
your failure and consequence significant
consequence is on the narrative your
games are you know they're that they're
different as individuals if you compare
one to the other they're different but
people know what it's sort of a Quantic
Dream game is they know where you're
coming from and
why is it do you think that even though
you've been making these games and they
have been successful and selling and
seemed to be well critically sort of the
claims are received why is no one else
making these games is that weird to you
like you know I think the situation has
changed a lot to be honest with you
since we started because when when we
really initiated this new Jean maybe
with Indigo Prophecy
we were pretty much alone to believe in
this story driven game with branching
narrative and I remember very well that
it was very challenging to convince
publishers write the time to sign these
kind of experiences because they said
well there is no shooting in your game
what kind of game is it going through it
so we are now you know ten years later
and I think things have changed a lot
because now we can see some story driven
games arriving and and we can see most
of all more and more storytelling in all
kinds of games right even in shooters
now you have a very strong story and you
have virtual actors and they try to
bring emotion so yeah I mean heavy rain
was a game that sort of you know back
then you guys were the first people it
seemed doing this sort of like facial
capture voice yeah within the game I
mean it seems like it's happening in
every game now absolutely is it easier
for you guys now because there's like
it's not like you're creating this
technology to put in your game it's is
it's more ubiquitous is it is it easier
to do that now is the technology become
sort of more yeah you know it's easier
and harder it's it's easier in that
sense that because there other people
are doing it then you know what the
benchmark is and what you want to
improve compared to others were where
you were on your own I mean you were
setting the benchmark by yourself so it
was like hard but it's more challenging
of course because now there is a lot of
competition and there are some very very
talented and skillful people out there
doing great things so it's it's some
pressure on the studio but but it's a
very interesting challenge and overall I
think it's a good thing for the industry
where as a wall that that we compete to
tell the best story and have the best
characters in our games and there's so
many support you I imagine quite well
and in this endeavor absolutely I mean
we came here 10 years ago in 2006 and we
had this short technical demo that we
created that was called the cast
that you can still find on YouTube and
actually we never worked with Sony at
the time and we just show them this
little piece and and they said okay we
would you like to be on Sony's booth at
e3 so yeah of course we that's a dream
coming true
and they put the demo on their booths
and it's been very successful we've got
very positive feedback and then they
came back and say okay what do you want
to do after that was it pitch them heavy
rain was it was that the video of the
lady and the kids oh absolutely and here
we are ten years later and it's been a
wonderful relationship honestly with
them for ten years
they really supported us always
supported us and even in our crazy ideas
even where the games are late or cost
more than he should plan which never
happens but still they were very
supportive and always pushing us for
innovation and and you know being
creative and letting us what we wanted
to do I mean total creative freedom
which is incredibly rare these days
yeah I mean and also sort of as you as
as a writer and director like you only
get video games to come on time to make
and and you only get to make a certain
amount within your lifetime yeah was
this a story that you always sort of
wanted to tell is this one you've had on
the backburner when you were making
other games like heavy rain and Beyond
did you always want to do your sort of
take on on the Android human
relationship no but but but I think the
the you can only I can only carry one
story at a time and but I know that this
is a story that I need to tell but it's
it's one thing at a time and there is a
moment where you you carry more stories
in you but there is a moment where there
is one right and you know it's the right
one it's the one you are going to fight
for over the next three four years of
your life and you know that you cannot
leave without telling that specific
story and it slowly grows in you it's
and it becomes something obvious at some
point and you know you have to do it and
I guess I've got a lot of questions sort
of I'm sure you won't be telling us too
much about it but about about Detroit I
mean the word Detroit in America as well
means something it you know that you
can't sort of think about that without
you know thinking about race relations
and sort of like
I guess like socio-economic issues and
things like that and obviously we were
talking briefly before we went live
about you know to sort of what's
happening in Europe at the moment as
well do you feel like you want to tell
those types of stories within your games
is there any of that in Detroit's itself
or it's sort of because that's it's it's
a difficult one it's like do you want to
have the responsibility a burden of
talking about these things you know
I chose Detroit because I was very
fascinated by the history of this city
it was an industrial giant and in the
20th century and then it went through
very hard times and now it's trying to
be reborn again somehow it has also a
fantastic history of as you said Rachel
you know Jews the cultural aspect is
also amazing with the Motown and all the
great ice yeah of course coming from
Detroit so it's a fantastic place but
it's also a great city with a great
history and this idea of being very high
and losing everything and coming back
right it's so strong and it's such a
human story somehow so that that was the
starting point for getting interested in
in Detroit and then we said okay we
cannot write about Detroit without going
there hmm I mean of course you can go on
the internet and grab some pictures and
then you know Google Earth it and and
there are lots of ways today yeah but
the thing is that you don't feel the
place you don't know the people so we we
travel there spend some time there of
course we visited the abandoned
factories and the abandoned church is
that everybody knows in all the urban
fields type of areas but at the same
time we we saw some wonderful things we
met some incredible people and the Fox
Theater for example in Detroit one of
the most amazing places I've seen and
it's it's right in the center of
Detroit's incredible and and the people
there are full of energy and they're
struggling and they're fighting but they
they are revitalizing the city in a very
interesting way and all this combined we
came back from Detroit really thinking
yeah this is the place where we want the
story to happen but this is a very
sensitive thing because
and that was also very important to us
is that if you choose a real place yeah
you need to do it in a very respectful
way because this city has its own
history there are people living there
and they love their city or this is the
place where they leave I mean you need
to pay attention to that and be
respectful and not just use what you
want to use for you gay and throw
everything away so we try to do it and
we'll see but I hope that people in
Detroit will feel proud of this game and
and the way we use their city ok last
question David thank you so much for
talking a lot right no it's great like I
mean I could talk to you all day it's
always fascinating to speak it's
somebody like you and I last question
what games are you playing right now
what did you have much time to play
games the Modi very busy what have you
played in 2016 uh oh I played a bunch of
things a little bit less this year
because the Detroit is taking pretty
much of my time at the moment I'm
playing a little game on iOS little game
great game it's called a human resource
machine ok it's sounds like work a bit
it sounds like work but it's actually a
very fun game to be initiated to
programming right though that sounds
very boring described like that but
actually it's a very fun game and if you
like puzzle games on iOS you should
check that because it's really
surprising in many ways excellent a go
game recommendation from David cage and
stuff thank you so much sir it was a
pleasure
looking forward to seeing more of you
become thank you
you